welcome to this exclusive training where
we are going to be talking about one of
the
most powerful skills that any youtube
creator
entrepreneur business owner or any
person with a
message or a mission needs to develop
and that's the skill
of copywriting now what's copywriting
like it's the
art of writing persuasive and powerful
words that connect with people and get
them to take
action this applies to your youtube
titles this applies to email subject
lines
this applies to the words you write on
social media it applies to the product
brochure
or website language you use and it
really applies to the big
idea that you come up with in regards to
promoting your products
your services your church your book
whatever this is a very powerful skill
and i'm so excited because today
we have a guest speaker a great friend
of mine named ray edwards who's going to
be
doing a 40-minute training
breaking down how you can write powerful
headlines write powerful youtube titles
and giving you some formulas
some powerful strategies and tips and so
i'm super excited for that but hey
if you're new here my name is sean
cannell smash the like button
and what you're actually seeing right
now is an exclusive training that is for
our inner circle community and we are
streaming
this first part inside of our private
facebook group but we're also giving
our wider community access because we
just believe this information is so
powerful when we want to get it into
your hands
so here's what's going to happen in the
next few minutes we're going to kick off
this powerful training with ray edwards
and so grab a journal shut out
distractions get ready for that
and then in the second part we're going
to go into the private facebook group
and do what we do
every single month with inner circle
which is hot seats where we bring people
on and talk about their businesses their
challenges their youtube channels
as well as deeper dive q a and really
sharing the behind the scenes of a lot
of what we do
at think media with our team our
strategies and our business
and so uh if you haven't heard about
inner circle before and you happen to be
watching this on youtube there is
details in the description below but you
can always go to
think innercircle.com and here's what
inner circle is inner circle is a
monthly business and marketing training
and we recognize we serve youtube
creators the most
but eventually you need to kind of go
beyond youtube youtube's like the front
end it's your traffic
and build a business around that how do
you potentially package your knowledge
and
your expertise into an online course how
do you create products how do you market
online how do you build websites
that actually get people to take action
how do you do copywriting the
top the topic of this very training how
do you build an email list how do you
uh write powerful emails that people
actually open how do you clean your
email list
how do you set up a crm how do you do
digital advertising and i want to remind
you inner circle that
you've got access to the inner circle
vault you've got so many powerful
trainings in there of course
bi-weekly we do q a only sessions
and so wherever you're watching this
just to learn more
uh you can go to think inner circle and
you can check out details in the
description
down below but with that i'm excited to
get into this training today
and i want to welcome ray edwards to uh
our community ray thanks so much for
being here thank you it's an honor to be
here i'm part of this community i love
this community
and i couldn't be more excited about a
training likewise i'm so fired up well
listen
we're gonna get straight into it and
then towards the second towards the end
of the hour we'll do a little bit of q a
with just
everybody before we kind of go into part
two of inner circle so buckle your
seatbelt
get a journal get something to write
with and get ready to
supercharge your youtube channel your
business your message your marketing
with ray edwards here we go
all right thank you so much sean it's an
honor to be here it's honored to be here
talking to you today about
how to write copy for your
youtube channel for your headlines your
titles and more
i'm a copywriter by trade i've had the
privilege of working with some pretty
well-known names in business and
leadership tony robbins jack canfield
um mark victor hansen michael hyatt many
others
and one of the things that people ask me
is what
what can you tell me about the little
getting intellectual property mark
that's
the kind of copyrighting we're talking
about we're talking about writing
powerful persuasive words
that sell your products your services or
your ideas or in this case that sell the
content
in your youtube video specifically i'm
going to talk about headlines today
and headlines are the big letters you
see at the top of the page to capture
your attention we're going to talk about
what that is
and why it's important to your youtube
videos because that's what
as you know the thumbnail and the title
of your video are so important
i'm going to give you some new ideas and
distinctions about how to create
powerful
titles for youtube videos and much more
so we're going to get right into it
what is the headline that's what we're
going to start with what is a headline
the headline is the copy
that sells the rest of the copy so in
this case it's a copy that sells people
and clicking on your video
to watch it it's the copy that gets you
the click now the mistake a lot of
people make with headlines is they often
want to sell everything in the headline
they want to make the sale in the
headline they want to sell people on
watching the entire video in the
headline or give the entire contents the
video in the headline
that's not what you want to do you want
to get their attention at the the point
of the headline is to get people to stop
the title of your video is scary able to
stop and click to see more
every piece of content must grab the
reader's attention you know this
as part of this community you're hyper
aware of this i know i'm going to give
you some tools you can use
to get their attention quickly and
reliably and you must start with your
viewers
state of mind on your mind and sean
talks about this in the vra system
he talks about asking and answering
specific questions which is a great
place to start
gary halbert gave another perspective
he's a great copywriter of years gone by
he's
he's gone home to be with the lord now
but gary was a great copywriter maybe
one of the greatest who ever lived
and he had what he called the gun to the
head philosophy of writing writing copy
and especially writing headlines and
that is if you put a gun to my head and
said this headline has to work
it has to get people to click what would
you write you'd get right to the point
you get into their mindset you know
what's taking place in the minds of your
viewer your listener your reader
and you focus on what they want and
that's how you write a
compelling headline or youtube title so
here are five essential qualities of a
compelling
headline or youtube video title and the
number one is to get attention
right this is what we want to do we want
to get attention you want to make a
claim or a promise
because that's what people are looking
for they want to know that you know what
they need to know
you want to evoke an emotional response
if you click on it
if you click on your youtube button on
your computer it pops up or your
your ipad or your phone and you see it a
title on a video that
gives you an emotional response either
makes you angry makes you sad strikes
the core with how you're feeling today
you obvious you often are going to click
on that because you want to
respond to that emotional response
that's how we're wired you want to stir
up curiosity
curiosity is key you want to appeal to
their self-interest because
when you're on youtube looking at video
titles what are you looking
for you're looking for things that
interest you it's the old what's my
favorite radio station w-i-i-f-m
what's in it for me that's what they're
thinking about that's what you want to
appeal to
here's some examples of titles that do
these things
can you really be younger next year now
i want to start
right now by saying i'm a big believer
in the answer specific questions
philosophy of creating titles for your
youtube videos
and creating your content absolutely
these go beyond that because
there's a time for that kind of hygienic
content and there's a time for things
that have a more powerful universal
emotional appeal
so we're going to dig into the deeper
elements of writing these headlines and
titles
can you really be younger next year as
an example which of these five mistakes
do you make on your youtube channel
is another example quality number two of
a compelling headline
screen and qualify the readers or
viewers you don't want people clicking
on your video expecting one thing
and getting something they did not
expect that's not going to give you good
results it's not going to give you good
watch time
they're not going to be satisfied with
your experience with your content and
it's not going to work for anybody so
you want to make sure your screen you
screen and qualify
your viewers carefully with your
headline titles
of your videos call out your tribe use
language to understand talk about
issues and topics that are of interest
to them if you try to talk to everybody
i know you've
heard sean say this try to talk to
everybody you end up talking to nobody
examples why new authors fail and what
to do about it
so who are we appealing to new authors
obviously
the top 10 ipad apps to manage your
youtube channel that appeals to a very
specific kind of person
somebody with an ipad somebody who wants
to manage their business with their ipad
and somebody who wants to manage their
youtube channel with an ipad that's a
very specific target
it screens and qualifies the reader or
viewer very carefully
quality number three of the five
essential qualities of a compelling
headline or youtube title
it gets skimmers scanners and scrollers
to stop and click
now this is important a
dear friend of mine a colleague of mine
michael forton once told me
people never do three things on the
internet they never read anything at
first they never believe anything at
first they never buy anything at first
i found that a little bit confusing but
he elaborated he explained it like this
people don't read anything at first on a
scheme they're looking for
words or images that keeps their
attention so they're skimming
they're scanning they've read they never
believe anything first
they don't believe what you're claiming
about your videos they're going to scan
through it
they may pop in the description and they
scroll
and your goal is to get them to stop
skimming scamming scanning and scrolling
and scamming don't let them do that
either and stop them from skimming
scanning and scrolling and stop and
click
to see what's your video is about or
your email if you're using subject lines
or your
page if you're writing a headline for a
blog post etc your headline's job is not
to make the sale
it's job is to make them want to read
the next line or watch the video
it's a very important distinction its
job is to make them want to read the
next line
in the description or the email or the
page
or watch the video examples
how to write a book in seven days that
is if i'm
trying to figure out how to write a book
quickly that's going to capture my
attention i'm going to stop skimming
scanning and scrolling i'm going to
click to see what this is all about does
god want you to be rich that's only
going to appeal to a certain kind of
person
faulty number four of the five essential
qualities of a compelling headline
you want to communicate the big idea
david ogilvy said no success no ad
campaign no advertisement
in itself can be successful without
having a big idea i know sean talks
about this a lot
i think media find the one true benefit
of your content the most appealing most
powerful the bedrock benefit
for when coming online to find content
like yours you want to what's the true
one true benefit to looking for that's
the big idea
of the video or of the email or of the
webpage communicated in a meaningful way
that's meaningful to whom to them
examples
triple your productivity instantly using
your phone
the customer is not always right why
that belief is killing your profits
this is only going to appeal to a
certain kind of person maybe somebody
who wants to believe the customer is not
always right because they've got a
problem customer they're trying to deal
with or maybe they're so tired from
trying to serve everybody all at once
and do everything everybody asks them to
do they're not realizing they need to
focus on their primary target customer
their best customer
to fuel and grow their business so these
are
deeply thought out big ideas for videos
or
emails or articles the number five
essential quality of a compelling
headline establish credibility
authority is a powerful way to gain
attention so if you have an authority
card to play don't be shy about it
play the authority card examples phd
psychologist reveals secret of
self-discipline
not what you're expecting these mit
scientists tell you the exact video to
make next
no i don't actually know mit scientists
who will do that but i'm sure they exist
now here's the next level of writing
youtube titles that i want to think
about and talk about with you and that's
audience awareness this is critically
important
you've got to know as some have put it
before me
the conversation that's already taking
place in the mind of the viewer
or the reader but it goes beyond that
you need to know their state
what state sit down and put yourself in
their position sit down at the keyboard
close your eyes for a moment and think
about where is my viewer when they
go looking for videos to watch or when
they scan their email to see what
they're going to click on
what are they thinking about what time
of day is it what my perfect customer
what are they doing at that moment in
time because that's the state you need
to match
i have a scale i created called the open
scale of awareness this is just about
marketplace awareness of the problem
that you help solve
so if you think about this scale it's
kind of a hack for thinking about how to
communicate with your audience in a way
that will be meaningful to them
oh and open stands for oblivious these
are people who don't know there's a
problem
or a solution and they're the hardest
people to sell they don't know there's a
problem
they don't know that they need a problem
that exists you don't have a solution to
a problem they don't think they have
those are oblivious people these are the
people that if you're selling vacuum
cleaners door-to-door
you know these people because none of
them know they have a vacuum cleaner
problem when you show up at their door
do they stands for pondering
they're vaguely aware they may have a
problem but
they don't really they're not really
sure maybe if to put it in
daily very average plain language let's
say
you think you might be getting the
beginnings of a headache i have a little
bit of a headache
i'm not sure maybe you're getting a
headache you're pondering what to do
about that headache
the e and open stance for engaged these
people are aware they have a problem
they may need to find a solution and
they're aware that there are solutions
available so
this person has decided they're maybe in
a meeting and they realize
i've got a headache i'm getting i've
really got a headache it's just starting
it's going to get worse
i need to think about getting some
tylenol or some other headache remedy to
help me with this headache
the n in the open scale is the need this
is the person who's in need
or is john carlton the famous copywriter
put it this is a person with a bleeding
neck they know exactly what they need
they need the
bleeding to stop from their neck they
they're desperate for solution they'll
do anything for a cure
like for a headache if they've got a
migraine they want the medicine right
now they're the easiest people to sell
the people who are in need
they know they have a problem they know
there is a solution they know that you
have the solution they're ready to buy
that's the
that's the kind of person you most want
to write your titles for because those
are the people who are going to click on
your headline or your youtube title to
get access to your video
so use the open scale to gain your
headline for different levels of
awareness
this is not to say you might never want
to create videos for people who are just
pondering
you want to educate them about there
being a problem definitely you want to
create that kind of content
but you need to think about your title
of your video when you're doing that
before you do so because that will give
you the keys to talk to them in a
language that'll be meaningful to them
as opposed to the person who's oblivious
or the person who just knows exactly
what they need they want to know what
your deal is
what you're offering you want to think
about
this and from the perspective of the
ground understanding
stand in their shoes look at it from
their position not from your point of
view because we all
know what we have to offer and we know
what people need we think we know what
they need
but we're not thinking from their
viewpoint nine cases out of ten
put yourself in their shoes and stand on
the ground that they stand on
and now i want to talk to you about
emotional quotient headlines
what is an emotional quotient headline
these are these go beyond
answering specific question headlines
obviously this is
i want to give you a caveat to using
these these are difficult to do right
and they're potentially dangerous but
they're super powerful when executed
properly
executed up a new word executed properly
emotional quotient headlines
find the one dominant driving emotion
that your reader customer or viewer is
experiencing as it relates to your
content
if you could sum it up in one word what
would it be would it be frustration
would be anger would it be envy
jealousy would it be fear
the key to making these kinds of
headlines work is to zero in on the
language
that most completely expresses the
emotion your prospects
are already feeling so that when they
see your headline they're going to think
or your youtube title they're going to
think
oh yeah that's exactly how i feel how
often do we click on
youtube videos because we know they're
going to confirm how we already feel
is it just me am i alone in this i don't
think so
once you find the right headline that
does this you can see this emotional
quotient in the opening of the video
in your copy and the development of your
material and speak to that emotion and
how
if it's a problem emotion prob if it's a
problem in motion if they want to change
then you're going to give them the keys
to making that change begin immediately
as they're watching your content you
make a transition from the emotion
uh i talk about the pastor framework i
should tell you a little bit about the
pastor framework
i don't have a slide for this so take
notes carefully
this is a framework i developed for
writing copy but this works for youtube
videos and content any kind of content
anytime you're trying to educate and
persuade people you can use this
framework to figure out how to
what elements need to be in your content
pastor
is about it's not about being a preacher
so you can relax about that
i'm looking at the original context of
the word which was to be a shepherd
and the idea is that you want to
shepherd your viewers to a place where
they make a good decision about whether
to watch your content
about whether to act on your content
about whether to answer your call to
action and buy your product or service
or
sign up for your channel subscribe to
your channel whatever the case may be
and you shepherd them to a good decision
about that by thinking about them first
so the p in pasture stands for the
person problem and pain
and this this goes directly back to the
vra ranking method
and you know exactly what i'm talking
about when i talk about the person the
problem and the pain you're talking
about who's your perfect customer
what's the problem they experience and
what's the pain they're feeling in the
way that they would describe it
and then you amplify that's what the a
stands for amplify
you amplify the consequence of not
solving the problem
if you don't get better at writing copy
for your product services and ideas if
you don't get better at writing
titles for youtube videos you won't get
the viewers you want you won't get to
watch time you want you won't get
the satisfaction that people have about
watching your videos because they won't
know they won't know
the title reflects exactly what the
video was actually about the problem
that it solved
so you want to amplify the the
consequences of not solving the problem
the consequences of not writing better
titles for youtube videos is you're not
going to get as many views not get as
many clicks
so you need to get better at writing
titles for your videos so that's
that's the amplifying the consequences
of the problem a also stands for
aspirations
you want to grow your viewers every
every week every day you want to get new
subscribers you want to get new viewers
you want to get people watching your
video all the way to the end you want
to get people who after they watch the
video they say man that title was
exactly what i was looking for in that
video was
answered the problem the question
exactly the way i wanted it answered i
love that guy i love that gal
they're tremendous they're fantastic
that's your aspiration
the s stands for a system
your struggle your system and your
solution so
you want to talk about in your copy or
in your video or your content you want
to talk about the struggle you've
experienced in solving the problem you
help people solve
so they know you relate to what they're
going through you want to
talk to them about the solution you
developed or you discovered or that you
use to solve the problem and then you
want to show them that you have a system
so they can use that system in the same
way to solve their problem for
themselves
and the t stands for the transformation
that's the changes you help them make
before and after
and also for testimony where you have
other people talk about your solution
and how powerful it is and how it works
for them
very well and the o is the offer this is
where you tell them what you're selling
and how much it costs and how to get it
and the r is where you ask them for a
response and
that's where you say click on the button
below and put your credit card
information and buy it
it's also when you say
click the subscribe button and watch the
so you get a notification every time we
get we put a video out
click the notification bell get all
notifications
it's where you ask them to give you a
thumbs up you're making a call to action
that's what the response
request is all about so when i talk
about make a transition from the emotion
the problem the pain and the
amplification of the viewer
into your actual content solution of the
problem that's what i'm talking about
in the context of the pastor framework
that's the teaching part of the content
the solution
so examples of emotional quotient
headlines are titles for you
why chasing lower glucose is a diabetes
mistake
by the way i'm not making that as a
recommendation it's just a sample title
that i don't work very well
for somebody i was working at for as a
copywriter
48 year old grandma reveals the secret
to slowing your age clock to a
c-r-a-w-l to a crawl
that headline was actually written by
copywriter carlene anglais cole for one
of her most successful promotions in the
health
field what every wife wishes her husband
knew about estate planning
and you can see how if you're in the
estate planning teaching business or
you have a channel about estate planning
and there are channels about estate
planning
i know because i've been looking at this
information lately what every wife
wishes her husband knew about estate
planning
is a key emotional impact
headline for a or a title for a husband
who's thinking about his estate plans
for his family and it's also a key
emotional title for
the woman who's married to him because
she wants to make sure he's going to do
it right
so you can see how this is appealing to
the dominant driving emotion in the
heart of the person
who might be looking and considering
clicking on your video
what never to eat on an airplane the
answer
anything don't eat anything on an
airplane
12 smiling swindlers this one is
a piece of copy a headline title that
was written by the late great clayton
make piece
who is a fantastic copywriter in the
financial world and he wrote for
financial investment products and so
forth and
this is one of his headlines and it was
referring to 12 heads of major
stock major companies in the stock
market and
there was a scandal at the time that
involved them not
not behaving well thus the 12 smiling
swindlers this was very meaningful to
the audience who would have read it
at the time so emotional quotient
headlines
or titles for videos are the most
powerful ones you could possibly create
they're going to have the most impact
they're going to be the most clickable
the most appealing to people
but you must be sure when i say they're
dangerous if you miss the mark you won't
get
very many clicks at all so you must be
sure that you understand your
perfect viewer for your video what
they're looking for
and that you have the content that
answers that question for them and that
way you can talk to the emotion that
drives them and want to have the answer
and that's makes you stand out a lot
more powerfully when you're
titling your videos and of course i
always recommend you test these things
as i know you're taught in vra video
ranking academy
so i'm going to give you 10 headline
templates
you can begin using as you think about
new and different ways of titling your
videos
or and not just about videos
how many of you here send emails to
promote your videos
well this is a great way to promote your
video by writing a headline for your
email
that speaks directly to what the video
is about and in the email you're gonna
write a little bit of copy
in fact we have some free resources
we're gonna give you today i think
there'll be a link in the
chat role about this where we're giving
you
headline templates email subject line
templates
and thought starters and we're also
giving you some templated emails that
you can use
just fill in the blanks customize for
yourself these are totally free to be a
download available at the link that'll
be in the chat
either now or later and you can grab i
have tons more of these for you
these are by the way these are like this
email subject line list that we're
giving you is my 100 best testing email
subject lines of all time
it's actually based on the millions of
emails we've sent which one's got the
most
opens got people to open the email and
actually read it
and the highest click-through rates
that's how we determine what those
hundred subject lines were
that they that they were the best
performing subject lines for us
so these are some of the forms you can
use to write
email subject lines youtube video titles
titles for your podcasts title for your
blog post
starting with number one the how-to
headline there's a reason so many books
start with the title how-to
because it works people want to know how
to do stuff
i'm just going to give you some examples
how you can use this headline if they're
going to look
suspiciously the same because they are
but they work and the key to making
these work for you
is to make them work with the keywords
and the emotional impact words that work
for your perfect
viewer or your perfect customer or
client how to lose 30 pounds in 30 days
so who's that going to appeal to
somebody who wants to lose
a lot of weight in a short period of
time for a very specific reason like
say they have a wedding coming up or a
bridal shower or something like that
they're going to want to and i'm and it
could be
somebody who's competing in some some
sort of physical fitness
contest it could be somebody who's going
to their class reunion and they want to
look a certain way
how to lose 30 pounds in 30 days could
be somebody who's going on a date
30 days in advance that'd be a long time
to know you have a date coming up but
i haven't dated in 30s
i take that back i date my wife i did it
this week
how to start a small group for
introverts he said is he backed out of
trouble really quickly
how to start a small group for
introverts how to clean your house in 30
minutes a week
how to sell more interior design more
often for more money
how to win friends and influence people
if that one sounds familiar it's because
it's a title of a book written by dale
carnegie
one of the most successful how-to books
of all time hence
uses this how-to templated headline as
the title of the book how to win friends
and influence people it's a great book i
recommend it
number two number two
kind of headline template you can use
the top ten reasons
headline the top 10 reasons why
to sell your house now bubble bulge
warning
this one could work really well right
about now
the top 10 reasons why you need to
invest in art
the top 10 reasons why you should buy
only locally produced milk
so you might not think about this kind
of
title or headline when you're thinking
about things like organic food and
locally produced milk
locally sourced eggs dairy products but
these kinds of headlines work really
well and it gives you a framework for
your content as well
the top 10 reasons why gold is a bad
idea with proof
so people who agree with you and
disagree with you you're going to want
to watch this to either
confirm their suspicions about why gold
is a bad idea or to disprove your proof
either way you're going to get viewers
the top 10 reasons why
you need to learn copywriting
number three the number three headline
template format
the secret way to headline
this is the secret way to do something
your viewer wants to do
desperately the secret way to be happier
instantly
the secret way to retire early and live
better
the secret way to know if they're
cheating on you
the secret way you will hurt your family
when you die
this could be through not planning
carefully not having things provided for
or taking care of in advance
not thinking of the people you're
leaving behind
could be lots of things number four
number four headline template form is
the
forbidden secrets headline now i know
one reaction that's going to come up is
going to be well this
seems kind of cheesy maybe a little
hokey
i know that it does but i also know
through testing these headlines
work massively well
the forbidden secrets of investing your
broker doesn't want you to know the
forbidden secrets of tax loopholes the
irs doesn't want you to know
the forbidden secrets of negotiating
your boss doesn't want you to know
the forbidden secrets of marketing your
competition doesn't want you to know
in each of these headlines or
titles we're saying suggesting
implying that there are secrets that
they're forbidden and that the person
whom we're playing the game against
doesn't want us to know about them
number five the who else headline
so this is where you're assuming that
you or the person you're
making the video about or writing about
already has the thing
that the person who's potentially going
to watch your video wants
and just ask them who else wants this
thing who else wants chiseled abs in
seven minutes
come on everybody knows there's no such
thing as seven minute abs
who else wants the secret of looking
young forever
who else wants to make money while they
sleep
who else wants your kids to obey the
first time
and like it can it get an amen from the
parents in the house
who else wants to stop pet accidents
forever i think when i wrote this one i
put accents in
quote marks because i think that moment
in time i was convinced that the
accidents were on purpose
that they were just trying to make their
point
number six the why don't headline format
this one is super powerful i've used
this quite a bit of late and i find that
people really respond to this
it gets a lot of clicks why don't
runners
have healthier hearts now let's break
apart what i'm doing here
you would expect runners have the
healthiest of hearts so am i saying that
all runners don't have healthy hearts
no that's not the implication it could
be but
the my first response to this is that
there must be something more
are they not eating the right diet are
they not doing the right other things in
their health routine
is it something genetic this is the kind
of curiosity that these headlines stir
up
that will cause people to click through
to see what you're going to tell them
what
what information do you have about the
thing you just told me
why don't weight lifters win fights
i don't really know that they don't win
fights it seems like they would but this
is a headline
that a friend of mine who's in the
self-defense market where
he sells how-to information to people
who want to learn
self-defense and this is something that
he contends is true
that people who just lift weights for
what he calls show muscles
don't know how to use them i don't know
i don't get in fights
why why don't your kids do what you tell
them
why don't employees just do what needs
to be done
so you see how those works those work um
so next is the amazing secrets
headline now again this is one that's
going to seem
and maybe feel a little cheesy but these
still
work when we run headline tests or email
subject line tests
these are the ones that get the clicks
not the only ones but they still work
remarkably well
the amazing secrets that make these
people
heart attack proof the amazing secrets
of the blind martial artist the amazing
secrets of people who work
a four-month year the amazing secrets of
ancient
chinese pain relief the amazing secrets
of the one-legged
golfer now that's an actual headline
for a real product that a friend of mine
john carlton
wrote many years ago it's one of his
most successful most famous
headlines for any campaign he's written
and it was based on a true story
he was doing his research when writing
for a company that sold
how to golf instruction products and it
turned out
the technique that was being taught in
the course was not mentioned in the
course that it was learned
by watching a golfer who stood on one
leg when he played
because he only had one leg and he
had some thoughts and techniques on
balance obviously
that were unusual and made him a great
golfer so these are the amazing secrets
of the one-legged golfer it's a true
story look it up
number eight the how to eliminate
headline our lives today
are filled with problems
challenges obstacles that we want to
eliminate
from our past if we possibly can and
sometimes we can't but
often we can if we know the methods by
which to do so so
these headlines work really well
especially in an environment like the
one we live in today
how to eliminate stress and anxiety
overnight
would anybody like to know that
if you're asking me
have a little talk with jesus maybe how
to eliminate doubt and uncertainty from
your heart
how to eliminate fear from your life
how to eliminate self-sabotaging habits
automatically that appeals to our desire
to
not have to work hard to make things
like this happen
and before you think that's a cop-out
there's a
there's a book called atomic habits
which talks about how to stack habits
link them together so that they happen
automatically every day so it's an
actual thing
how to eliminate worries forever
money worries forever number nine is the
how to set up
headline this is especially good in like
the online marketing
world or in the creator space
where people often want to know how to
set up things like funnels or don't know
how to set up things like cameras
or videos equipment setups battle
stations
how to set up a membership site in just
an hour
anybody intrigued by that how to set up
your day
for a win every time how to
set up the perfect first date how to set
up
your kids for success in life how to set
up your ira
to make you an automatic millionaire
the secret to that is actually just
automate your deposits into your ira
over about 20 years
number 10 the tenth
headline type template is the future of
headline the future of investing
not what you think the future of family
is under attack the future of your
office furniture
is less so if you
if you notice one thing i'm doing with
these examples is i'm
playing on the unexpected twist
or the curiosity invoking implication
like families under attack
some people will jump to the conclusion
they know my politics by
the by that headline they maybe do maybe
don't
the future of small business is not so
small
and this is where emotional connection
and knowledge about your audience really
comes into play because you've got to
know who you're talking to for
any of these headline templates to work
it's super important that you get that
that you understand whether or not
they're going to click with your
audience or not
but by saying the future business small
business is not so small
i'm actually this is something i'm using
in an upcoming email promotion and i'm
going to be talking about the fact that
this very thing that small businesses
are big
in comparison to what small businesses
were a year ago
because of things that happened then
five years ago then 10 20 years ago
because of the growth and explosion of
the internet
and how many people are online the
future of small business
is it's bigger it's not so small i
believe that as part of my world view
and it's one of the things that i
connect with people on so i know this is
great for my audience
it could be great for yours too just
because i said i'm going to be using it
feel free go ahead and use it fact you
can't copyright a title
the title of a book if i wanted to have
a book
called the seven habits of highly
effective people unless that phrase is
trademarked
which it may be but in most cases
book titles are not copyrightable in
other words you can't
claim that you own the copyright or the
intellectual property rights to a title
i digress the future of fitness both
easier and harder than you imagine and
this one
is is kind of a play on words and it's
also
gotten a built-in idea twist in it
because i'm thinking most people
maybe are not familiar with some of the
latest exercise
physiology and research and maybe things
like static contraction exercises where
you actually spend
a lot less time in the gym putting in a
lot more effort and it gives you much
bigger results or if you want
rock hard abs maybe harder than you
imagine
or maybe it's more difficult than you
imagine so there's a lot of
curiosity and possibility in this that
people will read into this
subject line or headline so those are
the 10 different types of headlines or
youtube
titles that you could use as you're
creating titles for your videos
um there's a lot more to to say about
this
idea of copywriting writing compelling
powerful persuasive words that
get people to click to get people to
stop the scroll
get people to click into your video to
click to open your email to read it
to click on the link in your email to go
to your landing page or your website
or your youtube channel so i've put
together these free resources for you
as a kind of a follow-up to this class
so you can have a lot of material to
work with
i have my 100 best email subject lines
these are email subject lines you've got
the best open rates from emails we sent
over an entire year
then we've got headline or subject line
idea starters
in a second resource and then i have
some free email templates
these are three email templates to get
more webinar registrants
more viewers for your youtube videos to
build rapport
and move more of your products and
services so these are all free to you
and they'll be putting the link in the
chat for the presentation and
that my friends is a wrap
yes man ray my mind is spinning
uh wrists are breaking from taking notes
and uh that session was so much powerful
content
i want to recap a little bit as well as
um take a little q a while we have you
but
if you got value out of this just hit
that thumbs up um
for all the value that ray has been
adding to
us today and a couple uh practical
things
uh to know i highly want to encourage
you grab that free download
from ray link in the comments link in
the description
and grab that he has tons of resources
of course i'd encourage you um he also
um
has a really good book we'll link that
up as well um
it's one of the best-selling books on
copywriting period
and um if you can see how powerful this
type of content
is it's called how to write copy that
sells step-by-step system for more sales
to more customers more often the
step-by-step system for more sales
to more customers more often almost 500
reviews
no miss uh book that she should pick up
from the legendary
ray edwards um and so uh check that out
um as well as you can grab that free
download and
you can probably see how powerful this
is right for using these headline
formulas
they give you it's really not even just
how powerful the youtube title could be
or the email subject line
or the way you open up a blog post or
even the first line of an instagram
caption but you're probably seeing how
powerful they are
for even inspiring your very ideas
themselves for actually
it's the big idea it's actually maybe an
idea of like oh i could really
uh run with that in terms of creating
maybe youtube content i saw
regan running with some ideas about the
future of
youtube and using those immediately uh
in terms of his niche and so um
let me know what your aha moment was
from this training
uh post that if you got a question throw
up four question marks before
and after your question we'll take a
couple questions in regards to
this um but uh the other thing i want
you to know about is we're gonna have
just a few more minutes with ray
uh and we were sharing this stream on
our think marketing channel
so you could actually we wanted to get
this information in your hands i wanted
you to know ray edwards because he's
just one of the most world-class humans
world-class business leaders and just
absolutely incredible
at what he teaches and
copy that cells these powerful headlines
are one of the most important skills to
learn so get the book get his free
resource
of course he has other programs and
stuff you can go deeper with so start
your journey by
uh grabbing that stuff and all the notes
in the description but this is also part
of our
inner circle program so if you want like
the replay
to this content as well as the exclusive
content after and what we have that's
called the inner circle
course it's over 25
different trainings on these types of
building blocks if you got
value out of this what would it how
would you like every month
to get content like this as well as
feedback on your channel
on your questions um on on these
critical building
block skills that just frankly a lot of
people don't talk about you know a lot
of people are helping you maybe with
youtube
and how to get views how to get
subscribers cool it's very important
it starts kind of building that
influence first but then what do you do
next
how do you build out products and
programs and
how do you market them what how do you
build a sales process how do you
go deeper into building a real online
business around the influence that
you're building on youtube
that's what's called the think inner
circle so if you want to learn more
about that think innercircle.com we'll
summarize all the show notes
uh and whatnot too of all these
different resources and uh
let us know if you have any questions
with that ray i kind of want to just
uh highlight a couple things that really
stood out to me i loved your audience
awareness the open scale of awareness
man if you try and talk to all four
groups your video
really won't connect with any of them
open obvious pondering engaged or the
need
and so i was like sharing this with the
think media team like hey
uh content creators you know nolan omar
like we need to be thinking about this
like who's this video for like are we
trying to talk to all four of these
but like who's the specific person we're
uh talking to
and then also the emotional quotient
headlines boom you about knocked me out
of my chair
like thinking about what's the one
driving dominant emotion
and i have encouraged people before like
there are certain videos where i have
led i've been like
you know maybe you're frustrated because
you haven't been getting views
on your youtube videos and then i'll
teach something related to youtube
but as you started to list through what
are some of the emotions
that you go because you you listed off a
list of them what are some of the
emotions that you kind of as you close
your eyes and think about who you're
writing to
that we should even be thinking about so
there's things like fear
anxiety discouragement uh
depression frustration suspicion
i know these sound negative but the fact
is these are the core emotions that a
lot of people are living in
and i'm not saying we want to fan those
flames we want to speak to them
and connect and lead them to a better
emotional state
so other i mean on the other side of
things there's excitement there's joy
there's anticipation
there's love i mean when somebody in
love
promise you love's the only thing they
want to talk about if you've ever if you
have teenagers in your home and
they've got a crush on somebody that's
all they think about all the time
and that's all they're talking about the
only conversation you can have with them
is about how lovely everything is
so these are i mean frankly we have a
few
go-to emotions most of us and especially
in your niche whatever
products or services or ideas you're
putting out there into the world
you probably know there's certain common
emotions that are happening
in the hearts and minds of the people
who are most likely to watch your
content or buy your products
or enlist your services so i would take
some time
to brainstorm those emotional states and
write them down and here's if you want
to go a level deeper with this
go look in like the comments on your
youtube videos on your social media
and see what people are saying about the
topic
that you are putting out information
or entertainment or content about and
when you see words repeated over and
over again like i'm so
frustrated with our current system i'm
so frustrated with the way this always
happens
i wish somebody would just blank those
are words and phrases you want to pay
attention to
because they're keys that unlock the
door to communicating with your audience
wow ray you just shared ten headlines
and of course uh watch the replay to
catch
all of those but jonathan had a question
i'm gonna hit a rapid fire
lightning round question round with you
now are the headlines in order of being
effective
or not or are those just 10 of the best
just 10 of the best
excellent um what would be
the best headline for the first email
for
a freemium email subject line what are
some ways we could open that first email
if you know what the the one thing that
your audience wants the most
is and that's what you're offering as
your freemium which it should be
like for this occasion i have the free
templates and outlines that i'm giving
you because i have a feeling that for
most people
on this training that's going to be the
thing that they would most desire for me
is could you give me
a bunch of those templates just
pre-written for me so i can fill in the
blanks
then you can just say free templates
available here
for whatever thing you're offering so in
my case it'd be like free email
templates
free blog post free video title tablets
can speak to the direct thing they want
the most that's what you should lead
with
speak to the direct thing that they want
the most
tiffany asks great question i'm worried
that there could be fallout from using
some of the
cheesy titles we've had negative
comments from click betty
baby headlines uh we've used out of 200
videos they've posted so far
any thoughts on that in terms of
fallout or when you should use them
advice
yeah it's it comes back again to knowing
your audience if you especially if you
had that response in the past
then take these templates and find a
different way to word the same thing
so you might instead of saying forbidden
knowledge they don't want you to know
you might say this confirms
why the industry never talks about this
topic
so that's a different way of saying that
in in less
cliched less click-baity as you said
i mean let's think about this not click
bait and by its strictest definition is
they click on one thing you give them
something different that's what the
actual clickbait is
although most of us come to think of
clickbait as meaning something that
makes us want to click
that's totally cool as long as you
deliver on the promise
in my opinion brilliant
uh should how should i best thank you
wendy for the question
um test how should i best title a bible
study series
to maximize click-through rate how would
you title a bible study series
well that depends am i doing this
bible study series with and four if it's
men in their 20s and 30s and we're
talking about
family and the whole family together and
how to be a good and faithful husband
you're going to write a different kind
of email than if you're doing a bible
study series for people who are in the
in their golden years in their 70s or
80s and you're doing a study on how to
finish well and leave a legacy
so it really all depends on who the
bible study is for it always comes back
to the who
man that was super powerful and there
was kind of little wi-fi glitch there
but
uh who is the bible study for man
knowing your audience means
you're knowing who you're speaking to i
love john maxwell's book on everybody
communicates but not everybody connects
and the first question he wants to know
when speaking on stage is not a
predetermined message
message but who's in the audience
because that's going to shape the
message
which kind of tees up this next question
i'll take this one uh
no i'll leave you that one for you i'm
going to take this one from josephine
and
uh so i've already created a video and
planned to release it tomorrow but i
don't have the exact words in my
introduction
as the title i want to change it
can i make the title slightly different
from the hook in the video uh absolutely
josephine i would say i think
there's two things i think about which
is
there's like layers of what we think
about i'll be honest actually
um you know because up until this point
i haven't been you know when people say
that like let me be honest with you
you're like you haven't been asking me
so far
uh but here's kind of some inside um
strategy of what we're doing
uh right now you know we have never done
this before as far as sharing a training
like this
also on think marketing because we just
wanted to get this in the hands of our
water wider community and give people
some exposure to what inner circle is
all about
however we realize that the wider
audience on think marketing
and if you're watching it there shout me
out in the comments we actually changed
the title we knew that youtube is more
of the desire
so the the leading part of the title on
youtube where this very stream yard
stream was scheduled ahead of time
is a little bit different and it's you
know whatever we type youtube title
formulas
because copywriting secrets
a lot of people don't even know that is
yet that's that was open levels of
awareness that ray was talking about
now inside of our inner circle program
where we're about to do hot seats in q
and a and go deeper for the second half
here
we just led with copywriting secrets
because we've discussed that a lot there
the importance of writing
copy that cells etc now furthermore
once i've thought ahead and i defined
those two different places even two
different thumbnails there's a little
scheduled thing for facebook schedule
for youtube
then there was the opening of this video
and this
live stream and so in a lot of youtube
videos when i open
i may say something related to the same
title but i like to write like three
four
five bullet points and think through um
if it was like is it too late to start
youtube you know maybe that's kind of
the title and i'd be like
you know is it too late to start youtube
in the midst of
rising competition is it even possible
to break through anymore
maybe you've been trying to break
through and you're frustrated as
there's that emotion um but at the same
time
in the midst of all this opportunity
you're excited about the possibility on
youtube
and so i a lot of times will
try to get really clear on a mini
paragraph of how the video is gonna open
so josephine to your point
i think that the hook it should align
with the title but it might expand on it
or it might even be
different it's that opening grabbing
introduction of what you say
first in the video uh ray what do you
think about that i mean what what do you
think about
your you have a headline on video
because you're doing youtube too by the
way it's awesome to see how you're
applying vra
and your youtube channels ranking for
different videos uh but what do you
think about you're gonna title your
youtube video and then you have the
opening first couple sentences
i think that is perfectly not only i
think it's okay i think it's good
because you know we never know exactly
how our title is going to land
and being able to use the title the
initial title to
grab some attention some eyeballs and
then to
elaborate on that a little bit and
you're still all the things you said
still related to your initial title
but you were kind of moving the the lens
of the open scale around a little bit
and the lens of the emotional
temperature of the potential viewer a
little bit
to include them so as they're listening
for that 20 30 seconds
they can feel like oh that's me that
first thing was not me but that is me
i'm sticking around i think that's
golden
well ray uh i have been super grateful
listen buckle your seatbelt everyone
because we're about to go into kind of
second gear here
a couple recap on some resources and
then we're gonna go into part two
um in the description you can see uh
ray's got a great book if you want to go
deeper on this
uh save this video you know maybe share
it with somebody um
and definitely catch the replay for all
the details if you haven't
grabbed rey's free resources this could
be one of the most valuable things you
have you'll have
this best templates uh
from ray edwards free download with i
headline idea starters
they're actually not just going to help
you with what the title is going to be
it'll be the very video idea yourself
and a hundred of the best subject lines
and email templates
really powerful things you can grab it
for free at uh
bit.ly forward slash headline templates
if you're using a bitly link and you're
hearing my voice and trying to
type that in capitalization matters but
the easiest way to get there would be
just click the link in the comments or
the
resources list description whatever so
definitely check that out
and then again this was just a sneak
peek preview
into our inner circle monthly program i
want to thank you so much
for being here think marketing community
and if you want to take the next step
and learn more about that go to think
innercircle.com link in the description
down below
if you're serious about building
full-time
freedom on youtube and not just creating
a youtube channel
um but finding out multiple different
ways to monetize and how to really build
a business around that youtube channel
in the inner circle course
we cover legal protection we have social
media and youtube lawyers in there
business structure
copywriting email line uh social media
they how to amplify your youtube channel
and other social media platforms
email marketing online course creation
lead back
magnet creation how to create a freemium
it's one of the most
valuable business online business
resources on planet earth period so uh
that's a pretty bold statement i guess
but really believe that and again if you
want to learn more think innercircle.com
and there's details in the description
down below
uh until next time click or tap the
screen to watch another video from
this channel on think marketing smash
like if you got
value and i can't wait to see you in a
future episode of the podcast
or on one of our shows